While Netflix is good for an afternoon of
binge-watching your favorite TV shows, it
has a great movie selection, too.
Even though the titles Netflix offers change
from time to time, they consistently offer
up some really great movies, from older classics
to more recent treasures.
Do yourself a favor and add to your queue
these hidden gems on Netflix.
Kagemusha (1980)
Akira Kurosawa's Kagemusha stands as one of
the legendary director’s finest works.
Amazingly, Kurosawa could not secure financing
for the film in Japan, prompting Kurosawa
fans George Lucas and Francis Ford Coppola
to get 20th Century Fox to produce it.
The sweeping epic won the Palme d'Or at Cannes
and reignited Kurosawa's career.
The Last Unicorn (1982)
Yes, The Last Unicorn is an animated children's
movie, but don’t lump this haunting and
beautiful tale in with the usual Disney fare.
For starters, the gorgeously unique animation
style might be familiar to some viewers, as
the core members of its animation team would
go on to form Japan’s Studio Ghibli.
The tale is brought to life by a stellar voice
cast that includes Christopher Lee, Jeff Bridges
and Mia Farrow.
And the enchanting score is provided by '70s
soft rockers America.
“At the last unicorn.”
The Thin Blue Line (1988)
Long before Making a Murderer, there was The
Thin Blue Line.
Former private detective Errol Morris directed
this chilling documentary with the intention
of bringing more attention to the case of
Randall Adams, a man sentenced to death for
the murder of a police officer.
Morris' work paid off when his film, and the
many discrepancies in the evidence and testimony
it uncovered, prompted officials to reopen
the case, eventually exonerating Adams and
overturning his conviction.
Things We Lost in the Fire (2007)
Benicio del Toro portrays Jerry, a struggling
heroin addict trying to reconnect with life
and love.
He's joined by Audrey (played by Halle Berry),
who faces her own uphill climb as a recently
widowed mother of two.
This drama avoids the formulaic and focuses
on the poignant—and with stunning performances
from both Berry and del Toro, it's a must-watch.
Dope (2015)
This coming-of-age dramedy puts self-described
"geek" Malcolm (Shameik Moore) and his friends
in a difficult position when his application
to Harvard is jeopardized by a drug deal.
Moore gives an outstanding performance, and
director Rick Famuyiwa pulls us along on a
wild ride with a smart story that's downright
hilarious at times.
“You probably got like one of those photogenic
brains”
“You mean photographic memory?”
“What did I just say?”
“I mean yeah, you said it.
Yeah, reiterating.”
Beasts of No Nation (2015)
Netflix made its first major foray into original
films when it acquired Beasts of No Nation.
Directed by True Detective vet Cary Fukunaga,
it tells the harrowing, powerful tale of a
West African child caught in a civil war and
recruited to a rebel militia as a child soldier.
Idris Elba gives a commanding—and terrifying—performance
as the militia leader who orders his soldiers
to perform ever more horrific acts.
The Fundamentals of Caring (2016)
Another winner from Netflix's stable of original
films, The Fundamentals of Caring takes the
"road movie" formula and gives it an offbeat
twist.
“Ahhhhh, help me, help me, Ahhhhh!”
Paul Rudd and Craig Roberts team up as, respectively,
a caretaker and a teen afflicted with muscular
dystrophy out to explore the country and themselves
(while picking up a hitchhiking Selena Gomez
along the way).
Writer-director Rob Burnett's deft touch with
the material makes for an enjoyably diverting
journey.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us the rest
of us know about your favorite little-known
Netflix gems.